Friendly greetings to everyone.
My name is is all night and I promise to you that the pronunciation of my name
is going to be the most complicated thing is is
this piece of work is a collaboration between Activision blizzard,
the University of Santa Rosa and the Technical University of Vienna.
The quest here was to render images with Reni,
high quality subsurface scattering in the mealtime on commodity hardware.
Okay.
Normally to render photorealistic images,
we populate a scene with objects,
add the camera and the light source and start tracing race from the camera to
determine the income ingredients.
Now even though there is a large volume of research going on on how to do this
efficiently,
this is still a really time consuming process.
What's more this figure here shows light transport only between surfaces,
meaning that we suppose that rays of light propagate only impact if we extend
our program to support participating media,
we can render a volumetric effects like smoke,
haze and many others and also translucent materials such as skin,
plant,
leaves,
marble wax and so on.
However,
this extension bumps up the dimensionality of the immigrant we need to solve.
Making the process even more time consuming.
Okay,
but the reward for this is immense.
You're on the left.
You can see how our skin would look like without subsurface scattering.
It is indeed a very important factor in the visual appearance of many
translucent materials.
It is not a surprise that the motion picture and the game industries are
yearning for a realtime solution for this.
There are fortunately simplified models to render subsurface light transport in
optical take materials.
What we do here is take an infinite Hoff space of a chosen translucent material.
Lighten infinitesimally thin pencil beam from evolve in normal incidence.
This beam will penetrate the surface of the material and you start to attenuate
as it becomes more and more submerged into the media.
During this process,
these forums undergo many scattering events and eventually exit somewhere away
from the origin.
Counting up these photos exiting at different distances.
We can build a histogram that we call diffusion profile and we'll denote as rd.
This is an actual simulated diffusion profile.
What it looks like.
If we look from above.
Another important bit of preliminary knowledge is that we can directly use these
diffusion profiles by come rolling down with an input irradiance map to add
subsurface scattering to it as a prosperous assessing step.
This is how the result looks like after the convolution is applied.
Now this is remarkable as we don't have to run a fully ray trace simulation with
participating in media.
However,
these signals are stored as images,
so normally this means that we compute a two D convolution between them.
Unfortunately,
this is very costly,
but there are techniques to reduce this problem to several much cheaper one.
The convolutions
one example is the old excellent technique.
He takes into consideration that in a homogeneous and isotropic medium,
the diffusion profiles are radially symmetric.
Therefore,
it is possible to take a one these slice off this profile as shown below here
and trying to fit it with a some of costumes which are individually also
radially symmetric.
This means that we can use a cheaper set of one de convolutions instead of using
the two d profile directly.
This is an example input signal and the results were Dion's technique,
but different number of costs.
Ian's compared to the true diffusion kernel,
it is important to point out that even the mathematical properties of costumes,
this technique requires one horizontal and one vertical convolution for Garcia.
These are one the convolutions.
This also means that if we'd like to obtain high quality subsurface scattering,
we need at least four Gaussians and therefore eight convolutions.
This is not suitable for most real time applications.
However,
it is a really smart idea and it hasn't been really improved since 2007 and
honestly,
when we started this project,
we didn't think anyone could realistically come up with something that's better
than this.
Our quest wasn't nonetheless to obtain high fidelity results with a separable
kernel using only two convulsions,
which is marked with green up there.
Okay.
This utilizing the Svd of the diffusion profile,
it is clear that the signal is not separable.
It is not possible to write this to the function as a mere product of one d
functions.
However,
the seminar plot tells us that the higher rank singular values decay came
rapidly.
Meaning that most of the information here is not random.
It has a lot of structure.
Therefore,
a rank one approximation sounds like a good starting point.
The plan was to treat the diffusion profile here on the right as a matrix for
which we compute DSPD.
Here you can see the one singular value that we're taking and the corresponding
left and right singular vectors that we hear the note by a,
we don't compute one horizontal and one vertical convolution using these
singular vectors to reconstruct the diffusion kernel and obtain the,
this is the input and the rank one SVD reconstruction.
This will be the ground truth and now we can see that the separable svd
approximation is indeed looking very grim.
There is a world of a difference between the two,
so wow,
this is surprising,
especially considering the fact that the Eckhart Young CRM teaches us that the
SPD is the best reconstruction in terms of different venues,
norm,
which corresponds here to the RMS error.
This is the absolute best reconstruction we can obtain with respect to the RMS
error.
Very disappointing.
Yeah.
Algorithm.
The one with the one the slice and fitting with one golf seeum.
This means the same amount of convolutions and hence the same execution time as
the rank one svd and the ground truth.
This is how the SVD looks like on the real world seem compared to using the true
kernel.
Looking at it again in our disappointment,
we noticed that the SVD overall darker image.
Therefore the reconstruction is not energy conserving.
Okay.
A new idea came up.
Maybe we would try this before putting the project on ice and calling it today.
What if we would solve a minimization problem where the reconstructed colonel
would still be as close as possible to the diffuse and profile,
but would also be energy conservant.
This should definitely be a viable option and the results are dreadful.
Horrendous.
I just,
I just don't know what to say.
Look at the nose somehow as if the input,
the radiance signal showed up as I'm really nasty ringing artifact and we had
the same around the ear.
Visualize the actual kernel on a disk of light to see what went wrong here.
And yes,
we see that it is indeed traps for nothing like the simulated difference in
kernel,
but we hadn't the slightest idea why this happened.
Visualizing the kernel itself in a simple one,
the plot and staring at it for a while.
It looks like the great separable approximation with respect to the RMS are most
of the energy of the signal is close to the origin and the optimized and tries
to reconstruct these details as closely as possible.
Please note that the colonel plots are deceiving.
These signals indeed have the same amount of energy,
but the tail of the fish is extending or really far away,
and this makes up for the seemingly less energy of the signal.
This very delicate thing took a week of my life and I kind of want it back.
So what if we would minimize not only the RMS terror by itself,
which of course is the optimizer to concentrate the energy to the origin of the
signal where the energy spike is,
but we would add a guide function which behaves like an envelope that tells the
optimizer to possibly because struck the regions not close to the origin.
Let's focus a bit more on foreign scattering.
This is the originally had and this is a very simple distance weighted guide
function.
I had in mind
imagined that we now have a more general model for which we used k equals zero.
That constant envelope to obtain these horrendous results.
I will now tell the optimizer to use k equals one which means that we would give
higher waist to the regions first or away from the origin.
This is what we obtained,
very intuitive.
We have a signal with the same amount of energy as if we pushed it from the top
to neglect the origin and add this energy to the tail of the signal to focus on
the reconstruction of firing,
scattering.
And now we can even go take was too,
which is essentially squishing the signal a bit more to emphasize foreign
scattering at the price of neglecting sharp close range details.
Okay,
back to the original fit.
Let's wait it by distance a bit by plugging cake was one in the optimizer
almost there.
Okay,
let's go.
Cake was a bit more emphasis on foreign scattering.
Now this looks remarkably close to the ground truth.
This is the journey behind the guided optimization technique that is separable,
requires only two convolutions and is one of the techniques we propose for
applications,
real time,
time constraints.
We also propose an other technique which we have mathematically derived and for
which I admit not having an intuitive story.
So before I dare showing you the next slide,
take a big breath and let's go.
So sorry,
this is solid.
It looks like and what is remarkable about it that this follows a completely
different paradigm.
What they're aiming for here is not to make our kernel closer to the original
diffusion kernel,
but trying to make the results of the commotion the same.
It is almost like minimizing the alto distance of the resulting convolved
images,
not the colonel stem cells staining for images,
not kernels.
This is impossible to solve for a general case,
so in order to accomplish this,
one needs to confine the solution to a class of empathy.
Radiance signals,
input images,
right,
would work well in our derivation.
We plugged in one day signals as inputs.
This means that the technique should behave analytically on signals like this
and the most remarkable thing that this is a mere rank,
one separable approximation that is really analitics for this class of signals.
This means that it mimics the effects of the true kernel perfectly.
Let's take a look at this on a practical case.
Of course,
not all signals are one.
The signals,
this is our result with the analytic preintegrated kernel and the ground truth
very close to being indistinguishable.
Furthermore,
it is really simple to implement and it has a closed form solution that does not
require any kind of optimization procedure.
One more interesting detail for the more curious minds.
This technique is for a greater class and only one these signals a class that we
call additively separable signals.
Okay,
so what about artistic editing?
The paint integrated technique is great,
but it does not offer any kind of artistic control over the output.
The guided approximation requires optimization,
but in return it also offers some degree of artistic freedom on how the desired
output should look like.
Okay.
We also have this technique which is simply using two separable Gaussians of
different variants values,
one each to provide perfect artistic freedom in adjusting the magnitudes of
clothes and foreign scattering.
Note that these two godsons are not the same as Indians approach with a two
Gaussians as we don't use the radially symmetric one,
the signal directly.
Okay.
A real world example.
This is the input irradiance heavily saturated barring scattering.
Yeah,
have an exaggerated close range scattering and the moral conservative.
Really good looking mixture of the two.
Wrapping it up.
DSPD is great for applications that can afford higher rank reconstructions.
The colonel integration is a simple technique that is analitics for additively
separable signals,
guided optimization,
or more general version of the paint degration that can be conveniently today
with one parameter.
Okay.
Manual approximation,
many degrees of freedom for artists.
While it has a quite reasonable accuracy that is comparable to forgo osteons
with previous techniques,
different techniques with different levels of scientific rigor and different
target audiences.
Arranging from scientists to artists working in the industry.
Now,
even though we used examples with skin to demonstrate our techniques,
it is important to point out that they work for a variety of translucent media
such as plants,
marble,
okay.
In his still life
and milk.
The most important take home message from this project,
at least for me,
is that it's entirely possible to do academic research together with companies
and create results that can make it to multimillion dollars computer games,
but also having proven results that are useful for the scientific community.
Thank you.